wir beschäftigen uns äh die
Nachrichtendienste beschäftigen sich im
Wesentlichen mit lagerfeststellung und
lagebogen das heißt also jetzt konkret
auch auf die Ukraine bezogen geht es
natürlich das können Sie nicht nur beim
BND der macht es nicht zu öffentlich
nett die Briten und die Amerikaner da
können sie im tägliche Militärs lesen
die gar nicht schlecht sind zu sagen da
steht auch nur die Hälfte drin
logischerweise der Rest ist eben nicht
für publikon Sunshine aber wiederum kann
ich mich sehr schön auf die gestrige
öffentliche Anhörung beziehen und da
wird auch sehr klar und hat der Karl
sehr klar gesagt wir schließen den
Einsatz von taktischen Nuklearwaffen in
der Ukraine nicht aus es ist derzeit
nicht konkret absehbar es ist klar das
muss man auch sagen Herr Putin selbst
möchte eigentlich auch überleben ja und
möchte diese Form der vertikalen
Eskalation mit potentiell unabsehbaren
Folgen die steht ganz hinten ne er droht
damit das ist ganz klar um einfach die
Hürden für eine konsequente
Unterstützung der ukrainischen
Streitkräfte und der Ukraine eben so
hoch wie möglich zu setzen aber was wir
erwarten müssen erst einmal den nächsten
Monaten ist was ich vorhin erwähnte wenn
man nicht im Felde Erfolg hat aus
russischer Sicht dann geht man eben in
die Weg der Horizontalen Eskalation und
horizontale Eskalation heißt also es
wird eben wie jetzt gerade auch
geschehen wird der Ukraine nach
Möglichkeit ein kalter Winter beschert
ein Winter der Entbehrungen und zugleich
wird man so etwas auch erwägen
gegenüber Deutschland halten sie atomare
Eskalation für möglich für
unwahrscheinlich hochschwellig ja das
heißt also nichts was wir in den
nächsten Wochen oder Monaten ohne eine
weitere Lageveränderung erwarten müssen
jetzt wird erst einmal versucht mit
denen jetzt absehbaren Mitteln einfach
den Willen das muss man sein das ist ja
der Punkt den Willen des Gegners in dem
Fall also dann primär erstmal der
Ukraine aber dann auch von Unterstützer
starten ja zu beugen
wenn es geht zu brechen wenn man im
Felde nicht weiterkommt Zeit zu kaufen
denn ich meine sie merken ja auch
Unterstützungsleistungen werden ja auch
von Russland nicht auch so netten
Staaten wie Iran oder eben auch
weißrussland ist herangezogen die Russen
müssen mit Sicherheit zwei drei vier
Monate noch berechnen um wie das sich
mit wenigstens Verbrauchsmaterial
einigermaßen einzudecken militärischen
etc ist nicht so schnell produziert
werden können aber das Theater leider
das traurige Theater wird absehbar
weitergehen
da putin wird da jetzt die Chance
zu fassen sie halten die atomare
Eskalation gerade nicht für das letzte
Mittel das letzte Mittel der Krieg wird
weitergehen und Verhandlungen sind
erstmal nicht in Sicht so ist es
so einfach ist das solange beide Seiten
solange beide Seiten den das Ergebnis
auf dem Felde erzielen wollen aber es
ist ja furchtbar wenn man überlegt wie
viel Soldaten auf beiden Seiten sterben
ja also es heißt der Krieg kann sich
auch noch fünf Jahre lang ziehen
auch das kann man das ist jetzt so lange
dass man das nicht seriös
drucktostizieren kann ja aber auf eine
absehbare Zeit das ist halt ein
abnutzungskrieg das heißt der derzeit
wird immer noch darauf spekuliert auch
gerade auch von russischer Seite wir
haben so viel Sie wollen wir haben so
viel geopolitische geostrategisches
Hinterland wenn Sie wollen ja wir
brauchen Zeit ja wir haben Ressourcen
wir sind zwar
einigermaßen unterlegen ja im taktisch
unterlegen aber wir können das durch
Masse ausgleichen und wir haben unter
dem Aspekt den längeren Atem das wird
wahrscheinlich soweit das erkennen
können die Philosophie sein
wir haben erst einmal den längeren
militärischen Atem und die Frage ist
bloß wie wirken sich die
wirtschaftlichen Einschränkungen
gegenüber Russland dann auch
demoralisierend auch für die Elite aus
da gibt es erste Zeichen dass man nicht
so sehr begeistert ist ne
was heute noch gar nicht absehbar ist
ist ob das jetzt wirklich Substantiv ich
würde gerne einmal bei dem
wirtschaftlichen Aspekten bleiben und
erfahren halt fragen wie lange kann es
denn Deutschland wirtschaftlich
überhaupt aushalten
das kommt auf das Niveau der Zerstörung
an die wir akzeptieren wollen wenn sie
natürlich
eine eine Fortsetzung des Konfliktes
über Jahre haben und wir unsere
industrielle Basis zerstört haben dann
reden wir mal so eben über einige
Millionen Arbeitsplätze aber deswegen
darf man glaube ich nie die Hoffnung
aufgeben dass es immer wieder auch
Zeiten gibt indem man einen
diplomatisches Fenster nutzen muss ich
glaube das kann man nicht einfach nach
dem Motto sagen
wir müssen jetzt
Russland besiegen das heißt die Frage
ist wer hält das länger durch das fällt
eine Diktatur immer länger durch als ein
Demokratie und es ist noch gar nicht
ausgemacht ob bei der mithörens in einem
Monat
die Republikaner den die Mehrheit im
Kongress und dem Senat haben und wenn
Sie Herrn Trump hören und er sagte ich
hätte den Krieg sehr schnell beendet ich
werde so Pudding hingefahren mit dem
beendet und wir wissen das wäre
wahrscheinlich zulassen
wahrscheinlich der der Ukraine getroffen
wäre aber
das ist zumindest auch etwas was wir
bedenken müssen wir sind nicht alleine
auf der Welt und die Amerikaner gucken
schon die Republikaner sehen schon dass
es am Ende nicht auf Dauer sein kann
dass Sie jeden Monat 10 Milliarden
rüberschicken nicht meine die haben ja
Gott sei Dank für Sie aus ihrer Sicht
nicht die Zerstörung die wir zu haben
ich meine wenn es darf immer nicht
vergessen ich habe vorhin von 50
Milliarden die uns die Stromkosten nicht
das würde man ja gerne für
Entwicklungshilfe ausgeben oder für
unsere eingebürger ja jeder Arbeitsplatz
der hier verzert wird kostet auch am
Ende
Wohlstand und wird hier gerne eine noch
einmal noch mal Frau Melnik Fragen hängt
es denn dann mehr eigentlich an dem
amerikanischen Präsidenten als an
Deutschland ich würde nicht sagen das
hängt wirklich am Besten vom Besten ab
und ich muss sagen der Westen das ist
aber Amerika ist der größere Hebel ja
aber der Westen an sich ist kein
einziger Staat und wenn wir als
Gemeinschaft der die eigentlich aus
mehreren Staaten besteht nicht in der
Lage sind ein Einfluss auf ein
autoritären Staat auszuüben was können
wir dann und ich glaube der nächste
Punkt ich habe das Gefühl wir beurteilen
immer Russland als ob Russland immer aus
der Position der Stärke agiert und die
Ukraine aus der Position der Schwäche
immer am Anfang ich glaube viele wurden
überrascht dass die Ukraine dann mehr
als drei Tage durchgehalten hat und das
ist ein großer Irrtum ich glaube nicht
nur wir sollen diesen Winter überstehen
wir sollen auch schauen wie ihr
eigentlich Russland das meistern